اذا قد يكون ترامب اول رئيس امريكي حالي
او سابق يواجه اتهامات جنائيه بمثوله امام
محكمه في نيويورك الا انه لن يكون اول
رئيس يتم اعتقاله بحسب تقرير لموقع
الاذاعه الامريكيه العامه قصه اول رئيس
امريكي يتم اعتقاله
في الواقع كان رئيس الثامن عشر للولايات
المتحده
الذي تولى الرئاسه في الفتره من
1869 الى
1877 هو اول رئيس يتم اعتقاله حدث ذلك عام
1872 عندما تم ايقافه خلال التحقيق في
عمليه دهس ام وطفلها بعربه تجرها الخيول
في العاصمه واشنطن الا ان الامر بقي
متكتما عليه لعقود من الزمن قبل ان يفسح
عنه الضابط الذي اعتقله لصحيفه واشنطن في
عام 1908 يقول الضابط ويليام لقد حذرته
مرات سابقه من تجاوز السرعه لكن في
النهايه الى اعتقاله لكن الرئيس يوليس لم
يكن ضمن المجموعه التي تمت محاكمتهم
ومخالفتهم عللا اذ لم يحضر جلسه المحاكمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]